[Music]
[Applause]
Chase Daniel recently retired NFL
quarterback and uh he has his own show
it's the Chase Daniel show on YouTube
the YouTube channel thanks for joining
us chase let's uh look at the state of
these two teams last night going forward
let me look at the Vikings at their
quarterbacking position and then the
Bears situation at their quarterbacking
position what would you do if you're the
Vikings at that position well I mean I
think you got to keep going with Josh
dos I mean if you actually look at what
he's brought to the table he's only been
there 28 days and yes he threw four
interceptions a four-piece I hate
throwing two interceptions the fact that
you threw four list and two were tipped
it happens but um you know Kevin OK
connell's comments after the game we're
telling we're going to evaluate the
position they're on bye they got jiren
Hall they got Nick Mullen okay Josh jobs
had that magic it looks like it's run
out a little bit and it doesn't look
like he's making bad decisions he's
still learning the concepts of the
offense um but I do like Nick Mullen and
I think they had Nick Mullins as a
backup for a reason so I wouldn't be
surprised if he gets a shot to to do um
what he does and that's just throw full
a lot of yards you look at like the
first 12 games of his career or 14 games
whatever it is he's thrown for the most
yards almost than anyone in NFL history
so he's got the talent to do it that
roster is really good you get just
Jordan Jefferson back um JJ so it just
it's going to be interesting to see what
they do they're still in a really good
spot for a for a wild card but we'll see
what happens but would you keep Kurt
Cousins like let's look at next
season you know that's that's difficult
that's difficult I I think that the way
it's trending and what I've heard I
think that Kevin oconnell and Kurt
Cousins um have meshed pretty well
together and that they are both open to
a return Kirk will get some guaranteed
contract again and we'll all on Twitter
go crazy like oh my gosh he just keeps
getting all this money um it's it's
insane but I do think that um where does
he rank Chase where like is he good very
good potentially great give me a label
for Kurt cousin you know from a
quarterbacking perspective yeah I think
he's very good I think that that his
scheme that he runs the receivers that
they've with Jordan Addison and JJ all
of them above he needs a good Supporting
Cast I don't think he's a guy that can
um without a really good Supporting Cast
around you go out and win you ball games
uh game after game I do love the way he
plays he's getting older right that's
the biggest thing if you actually if you
watch yeah I mean look dude I'm 38 I was
playing for a while too and and that's
that's usually what time like the middle
of the career Tom house okay Tom house
the Guru of throwing Tom Brady Drew
Brees all those he said like the best
years of a quarterback's life are in his
30s so he still got some gas in them but
it's going to be interesting to see how
it happens and what they're going to do
if that's the thing like you got to look
out there at the State of the Union of
the NFL and quarterbacking it's
impossible to find 32 starters that are
worth their penny so Kirk definitely is
one of those so if you're going to move
on from them you have to say to yourself
man we have a really good plan uh ahead
if you want to go with a rookie you know
I don't know if they're going to draft
really high so it's going to be
interesting I wouldn't be surprised if
he ends back up there in Minnesota yeah
I wouldn't either I know that uh Kevin
oconnell really likes him uh and and but
it depends on how much he's going to
cost which leads me to now with Justin
Fields right now you can keep him
because he doesn't cost you then he's
going to cost you and then you have to
decide is that a franchise quarterback
I'm going to make you the Bears GM right
now what are you going to do this
offseason season at the quarterbacking
position well right now they draft one
and four if the season ended today and
if the season ended today I would
absolutely say let Justin roll another
year or two I don't I think you pass on
a Caleb Williams or a drake may I think
in my opinion and this is going to be a
little bit of a hot take because people
don't really understand it I think he's
done enough to show that he can be
successful in the National Football
League given uh two things one they put
a supporting casts around them okay if
you go out there and you draft Marvin
Harrison Jr and you have Darnell Mooney
and you have DJ Moore out there that's a
heck of a Supporting Cast around him and
if you actually run an offense that fits
Justin you look at last year let's go
back to last year even before the
Patriots game that was the defining
moment for me they were running an under
Center play action scheme that they did
in in Green Bay with gy that's not
Justin Fields when they switched over to
an offense that actually uh used his
strengths okay he played really well the
last part of last year let's look
forward to this year the first three
games of the year they're doing the
exact same thing and Justin's struggling
that's not him he's not going to be the
guy to say hey versus cover two work
this side versus cover four work this
side hey man alert beaters no he's a
pure progression shotgun quarterback and
his feet um help him out so you have to
actually put him in a position to be
successful and I look I think that even
before Justin injury the last like two
or three games before he started getting
on a little bit of a heater and it's
continued last week Detroit yesterday
versus Minnesota and look everyone's
gonna be like oh those two fourth
quarter fumbles okay I've got so many
people on Twitter Dan saying oh look
well he's he's done he had two fourth
quarter fumbles well do you want your
quarterback to just roll up in a ball
after he fumbles the ball or do you want
him to do exactly what Justin did is
lead him down the field for a victory
that's what I want so in me in my
opinion it showed me more about who
Justin is is that two-minute Drive ah
all right write that down Chase says
that if he was running the Bears that he
would not take Caleb Williams or Drake
may you can see chase the Chase Daniel
show on YouTube channel all right should
Dak Pro Prescott be involved in the MVP
conversation here or is it a foregone
conclusion of who's going to win yeah I
mean no I think absolutely should be
especially because if you go to my show
and if you go to my YouTube show like I
break down Dak almost every week because
he playing at an unbelievable level and
a lot of people don't understand it what
he's doing and look look Mike McCarthy
got a lot of crap about when he fired
Kell Moore and let's let's just make
sure that it was a firing he let him go
because Kell Moore was top five
offensive um like staff gameplay and
whatever in the National Football League
the entire time he was in Dallas so why
did he fire him he wanted to run the
damn ball according to Mike well they
haven't run the ball at all they're
throwing it more than ever and after the
49ers game in Dak that whole offense
changed it changed completely and they
weren't they weren't as static as
anymore they're moving the pocket
they're they're motioning they're
shifting they're doing good things and
and CD Lambs come on as a true number
one receiver and you look week in and
week out I mean Dax stats in the last
five games are so telling to me so if
you're the quarterback of America's team
and you're the Cowboys you should
absolutely if you're in the playoff hun
be in the running for the MVP Most
Valuable Player I think without Dak
right now the Cowboys are a four or
five1 team but Jaylen herdz is the MVP
right
now I mean it's like it's like Jordan in
in his prime man like Jaylen never gets
too high with the high or too low with L
I mean you saw him after Jake Elliott
nailed the 59 y he was like okay let's
go win the game like I love quarterbacks
like that he's a perfect fit for Philly
get if Jay Cutler did that we would
crush him when he did that we crushed
him he's like he doesn't care he's
lethargic I like that man look at Jaylen
nothing bothers him yeah well you know
what it's not Jay Cutler it's Jaylen
Herz and it's Philly and that's what
Philly wants they want people to be like
yeah like got that Swagger about him and
honestly jaylen's been doing this on a
bum knee his knee is more hurt than than
than a lot of people think and the fact
that he's able to still run the ball
still gut it out and play I mean he's
becoming like a a hero right now in
Philly I can't imagine if they win a
Super Bowl what they're going to do with
Jaylen Herz probably build him a statue
yeah um I maintain I've maintained this
for years that it doesn't seem like the
bills have an offensive strategy or game
plan it feels like their game plan is
hey Josh uh help us out here and I'm
sure I'm oversimplifying it here but am
I oversimplifying it
by a
lot well listen when when I talk about
the bills um the the whole story is Josh
Allen and the whole story for me is the
turnover since 2018 he's led the NFL in
turnovers and it's not even close in
second place and that's the big issue I
didn't agree with the firing of Ken
dorsy I because the issue with the
Buffalo Bills offense is not the fact
that they're not really good in yards or
first downs or points because they're
top 10 in all the it's the turnovers how
are you going to put it on a coach okay
if your quarterback and your offense and
your running backs are turning the ball
over okay look I get it McDermot had to
make a move he made a move Joe Brady you
go back to Joe Brady and what he's been
able to do he got fired Midway through
the season in Carolina if you don't
remember if you don't if you forgot and
then he's actually gotten the last two
games I thought that what he's done is
he's gotten back to who Josh Allen is at
its score Josh Allen is not a let's go
through four reads throw it to to he's a
number one number two takeoff and that's
exactly what they're doing they're
giving Josh Allen half field reads when
it's not there he takes off and if you
look at the two-minute drive this was
really telling okay if you look at the
two-minute drive to take the lead
against Philly there were 10 plays in
that drive they went run run run run run
screen play action run run RPO like
that's what it is to me that's great
play calling because you're not putting
it all on Josh to have to do five seven
step drop backs uh every play down the
field so I do think right now they're
running the football at a really really
high rate and that's going to protect
Josh from himself which sometimes he
needs protecting from let's look at the
Chargers as uh is this on the coach is
this on the
quarterback like if you were going to
lay blame and you were you had to pick
one yeah um I mean if I had to pick one
it's on the coach I I don't I don't
necessarily think Justin um is playing
bad ball look a lot of people are like
they want to bring up the two-minute
drives and how many sacks he's doing and
that and that's that's that's fair but
he's in a position almost every single
week because of the defense to be able
to do that and I know a lot of people
like oh just okay that's not the case in
my opinion look they they went out and
almost beat like probably the top team
in the NFL in the Ravens at home okay
it's just not working for him this
season they are just not really good in
tight score games one score games I
think they're like 0 and4 0 and5 this
year so that's the issue and quite
honestly it's they're running out of
time I mean they're running out of time
um Staley's running out of time I love
Staley as a head coach I thought he was
excellent the team actually really loves
him I know people are mixed on him that
aren't inside that locker room but at
the end of the day um they paid Justin a
lot a lot of money Justin's gonna be
that quarterback for the foreseeable
future if not for his entire career
based on what he's shown so it's going
to be interesting to see what they do uh
in the next few weeks if they can get
back into playoff contention at all
because in my opinion if they don't then
I just don't know if Staley survives the
season yeah I don't think he does I I
agree with you on that and it's not
personal you know he went to Dayton I'm
a Dayton grad like I I my job is to put
personal to the side at least the best
that I can Tom Brady talked about you
know this is Checker is not chess
anymore in the NFL he's had some things
to say about the quality of play uh you
know Tom's not that far removed you know
from playing to get to the point where
it's get off my lawn Tom Brady uh your
reaction to What Brady's been saying
well I liked what Alex Smith said on on
uh on NFL Countdown or whatever he he
would he he said hey I disagree with
with Brady and I would tend to agree
with that look I I think Brady um he's a
different animal and anytime that Brady
says something you got to take it um
like I I take it pretty seriously and so
when I heard that it was interesting and
I get what he's trying to say I think
what he's trying to say is like hey the
game's gotten soft you can't no
Defenders are allowed to hit the
quarterback anymore all this stuff about
what's pi what's roughing the passer all
this stuff so I do think that this game
has really turned into an offensive game
because what sells points points sell
even though this year defense is at an
all-time high in the last 10 years the
average points scored per game is like
18 or 19 it's it's the lowest it's been
in like 10 years um so it's interesting
what he said and I get it and the fact
is like that interview told me like he
still wants to be playing like he still
has that competitive fire and quite
honestly you probably still could yeah
but Tom benefited from these rules they
changed the rules in part because of Tom
Brady you right he's he's trying to get
his broadcasting career with fo you
think that's what he's doing started so
yeah with his let's go podcast I listen
to it I think it's excellent but I mean
look you can say whatever you want in
the media as long as you you have
somewhat of a of an opinion and you're
good like it just doesn't matter well
he's the goat so that like it always
comes back to yeah but he's the goat
even though but he's the goat yeah the
game is soft you know Checkers to chest
F could you learn something from Brady
as his backup as many years as you were
in the league and you were with you know
Drew Brees and Shawn pton and what what
could Brady teach you that nobody else
uh teach you I mean I've I've backed up
some pretty good quarterbacks Breeze
Alex Smith um and and I think what's
interesting to me because I'm I'm I'm
obviously friends with Blain gabber and
Blaine backed him up in Tampa for a few
years and bla was because I I picked his
brain we were back in amugi and I I was
like dude Blain because we're pretty
we're pretty close I was like hey how is
it backing up Brady man he's like dude
it is awesome like he's a cool dude like
he does like and that was pretty cool to
me is like he he like Brady is this big-
time cele celebrity way bigger than
football um and he said he's just a
normal guy and that's what I enjoy like
I don't like and I've been around some
people and I'm not going to name names
but there's some people that just think
that they're just all high and mighty
and that it does but like he said he's
very just like he's very content he's
very cool very down toe but I think with
what Brady would teach you is like I
want to know like obviously like the
football x's and those are cool but like
there's all these little things like
Howie doctors up football I'm not
talking about the flight gate but
there's this mud there's this mud on the
football hold on here here we go I'm
serious every single quarterback mudate
mudate it's this Mississippi mud and he
has all what they put on basb yes and
when I used to play him the footballs
are such like this like golden brown
color so sck every quarterback has this
mud and it's legal you can do it but his
were just like extra shiny and it was
that Tom Brady effect on it so like that
or like how he like makes sure that like
he's crazy about his like Palm his on
his right on his forearm to make sure
it's not sweaty when you're throwing the
football and he has this like this stuff
that he does he stuffs um a uh a towel
down his Center's butt like all this
stuff is so interest interesting to me
that's what I would want to know because
I know for a fact there's so many more
things like that wait wait what do that
matter if the back of your right hand is
dry or not yeah so anything at all like
if if you're sweating that's why Bray
used to always wear sleeves and he
always had to have a hand muff on them
when you're sweating the the sweat drips
down and gets onto your palm okay and
when it's on your palm it then becomes
on your pinky and when you're throwing
I'm telling you right now it's awful so
he always had a tell he was crazy about
that and that's one thing Blaine told me
like hey there's this there's this like
some type of thing he puts on it and
then like it's this whole routine that
those are the little bitty things that
make quarterbacks great that they they
think about that I would have loved to
be his backup for okay explain this to
me and I've mentioned this on the show
before when Brady and deflate gate and
do I think that somebody deflated the
ball yes and I have no problem with it
it was lying to the commissioner Aaron
roders came on the show years ago and he
said I overinflate the ball and no one
said a thing yeah why have a rule why
why have a rule where you get to use the
football and then I get to use my
football who cares yeah I do think I do
think it's interesting i' I've never
once uh in my 14 years playing or even
this year covering heard of a
quarterback who over inflates the ball
like that to me is crazy like obviously
like there is an advantage to under
inflating a ball because it's easier to
throw and I'm it's like by one or two
PSIs it's not that crazy so it is a
little bit weird that you have this like
12 and a half to 13 and a half PSI that
the ball has to be within and I've
always enjoyed um if you're not if if
you don't have huge hands like under
inflate the ball so I get it but I don't
necessarily think that it I mean maybe
in cold weather games and that's what's
so crazy about Aaron Rogers he like to
overinflate it because the ball expands
no matter what in cold weather and so he
would under inflate it and I guarantee
you if they tested those balls in
deflate gate during the middle of those
really cold games they would be within
the 12 and a half to 13 and a half PSI
range because it's freezing coal in all
those games he's playing in January and
February so it's interesting to me um on
that with the with the Aaron Rogers
thing for sure always great to have you
on Chase and look forward to next time
and good luck with the YouTube channel
thanks for having me on guys that's
Chase Daniel the Chase Daniel show on
YouTube channel I like how Chase goes
you know whenever I uh mention the
Cowboys and break down the Cowboys my
numbers go through the roof and I go
yeah welcome to the analytics here